let R be the region in the first
quadrant enclosed by the graphs of f of
X is equal to 8 X to the 3rd and G of X
is equal to sine of pi X as shown in the
figure above and they drew the figure
right over here
Part A write the equation for the line
tangent to the graph of f at X is equal
to 1/2 so let me just redraw it here
just so that I like drawing on the black
background I guess is the main reason
why I'm redrawing it so the function f
of X is 8 is equal to 8 X to the 3rd
looks like this it looks like that this
is our f of x axis and this is our x
axis and we want to the equation for the
line tangent at X is equal to 1/2 so
this is X is equal to a 1/2 if you go up
here if you evaluate F of 1/2 you get F
you get 8 times 1/2 to the third which
is 8 times 1/8 which is 1 and they
actually gave us that already on this
point
this is the point 1/2 comma 1 and we
need to find the equation for the
tangent line so the tangent line will
look something like that and to figure
out the equation we just really figure
out its slope and then we know a point
that it's on and we could use there we
could you could use point-slope or you
can just use your kind of standard slope
intercept form to give an equation for
that line so the first part let's figure
out its slope and the slope of the
tangent line is going to be the same
slope as the slope of our function at
that point or another way to think about
it it is going to be F prime F prime of
1/2 or the derivative evaluated 1/2 the
derivative gives us the slope of that
line at any point so what is f prime of
X F prime of X is just the derivative of
this so 3 times 8 is 24 times x squared
24 x squared F prime of 1/2 is equal to
24 times 1/2 squared which is equal to
24 times 1/4 which is equal to 6 so the
slope of this line is equal to 6 I'll
use M for slope that's what we the
convention that we use an out when we
first learned it in algebra so the slope
is going to be 6 so the general equation
for this line is y is equal to MX plus B
this is a
this is the y-intercept we already know
that the slope is 6 and then we can use
the fact that the line goes through the
point 1/2 1 to figure out what B is so
when y is 1 1 is equal to our slope
times X X is 1/2 or another way to say
it when X is 1/2 Y is 1 and plus some
plus some y-intercept if I take X is 1/2
I multiply it times the slope plus the
y-intercept I should get 1 and so I get
1 is equal to 3 plus B I can subtract 3
from both sides and I get negative 2 is
equal to B so the equation of the line
is going to be y is equal to 6x minus 2
that is the equation of the tangent line
now Part B find the area of R so R is
this region right over here is this
region right over here it's bounded
above by G of X which they've defined a
sine of pi sine of PI X it's bounded
below it's bounded below by f of X or 8x
to the third so the area the area is
going to be actually let me just do it
I'll scroll down a little bit I still
want to be able to see this graph right
over here
Part B Part B the area of R is going to
be equal to the integral from 0 from 0
that's this point of intersection right
over here to 1/2 so let me make it clear
this is 0 to 1/2 0 to 1/2 and then the
the function on the top so we could just
take the area of that but then we're
going to subtract from that the area
underneath the function below or not one
way to think about it is the integral
from 0 to 1/2 of the the top function is
G of X which is sine of PI X so a sine
of PI X sine of PI X but if we just
evaluated this integral let me just put
a DX over here if we just evaluated this
we would get the area of this entire
area of this entire region but what we
need to do is subtract out the area
underneath the second underneath f of
we need to subtract out the area under
that so we just subtract from that f of
X and f of X we already saw is 8 X to
the third is 8 X to the third power and
now we could just evaluate this so let
me draw a little line here it's getting
a little bit messy it's getting a little
bit messy I'll just do it down here so
we need to take the antiderivative of
sine of PI X well the derivative of the
derivative of cosine of X is negative
sine X the derivative of cosine of PI X
is negative pi cosine of PI X so the
derivative the antiderivative of sine of
PI X is going to be negative 1 over PI
cosine cosine of PI X and you can verify
it for yourself and you might say wait
so how did you know it was a negative
well I put the negative there so that
when I take the derivative of the cosine
of PI X I'm going to I would get a
negative sign but that negative will
cancel out the negative to give me a
positive here and you said why did you
put a 1 over PI here well when you take
the derivative of this thing using the
chain rule you take the derivative of
the PI X you'll get PI then you would
multiply everything by and then you
would get negative sine of PI X and that
pi doesn't show up here so I need
something for it to cancel out with and
that's what this 1 over 1 over PI is
going to cancel out with and you could
do u substitution and all the rest if if
if you found that if you found something
like that useful but it's it's it's in
general a good a good habit or I guess
it's a good it's it's it's good to be
able to do this almost almost by sight
so and you can verify that this
derivative is equal to sine of PI X so
the antiderivative of sine of PI X is
this the antiderivative of negative 8 X
to the third power is negative 8 I'm
going to divide it by 4 so negative 2x
to the fourth power and I just all I did
is I incremented the 3 to a 4 and then I
divided the 8 by the 4 and you could
take the derivative of this to verify
that it is the same thing as negative 8
X to the 3rd power and we're gonna have
to evaluate that from 0 to 1/2 when you
evaluate it 1/2 so I'm gonna get I'm
going to get negative 1 over pi
cosine of pi over 2 cosine of PI over 2
minus 2 times 1/2 to the 4th power is
1/16 so that's it evaluated at 1/2 and
then from that I'm going to subtract
negative 1 over PI cosine of 0 let me
just write it out so minus negative 1
over PI negative 1 over PI cosine of PI
times 0 cosine of PI let me just write
cosine of 0 PI I can write or pi times 0
minus 2 times 0 to the fourth so that's
just going to be minus 0 so let's
evaluate this so to simplify it we have
a cosine of PI over 2 cosine of PI over
2 is just going to be 0 so this whole
thing just becomes 0 and then you have a
negative 2 divided by 16 that's negative
1/8 negative 1/8 and then from that I'm
going to subtract this business here
cosine of 0 this is 1 so this is just a
negative 1 over PI a negative 1 over PI
and then I have a zero there so I can
ignore that so this is equal to negative
1 over 8 plus plus 1 over PI and we are
done this part of it you're not allowed
to use a calculator so this is about as
far as I would expect them to get to to
for about as far as I would expect them
to expect you to get and so I'll leave
you there in the next video we will do
part we will do Part C